hi it's me Michelle from loudmouth and
beauty science and today I'm going to be
reviewing some products from crave
Beauty crave Beauty is a new brand
launched by Korean skincare YouTube
earlier you who kindly sent me these
products to review they don't usually
ship to Australia yet so I'm really
grateful that she sent them to me so
that I could actually get my hands on
them and try them out really early so
far there are two products available
callaloo young and the March a hemp
hydrating cleanser crave beauty is built
around the idea of simplicity that the
basics of skincare should be basic and
skincare should respect your skin and
they've definitely delivered with
diversity products crepe beauty is also
vegan cruelty-free alcohol-free dye free
fragrance free and essential oil free
firstly packaging I personally find
packaging really important and I like
things to look nice on my shelf and
Craig Beauty does look really good
there's lots of natural colors with the
packaging
there's even really nice natural colors
with the paper packaging on the outside
as well I'm almost afraid to throw it
out because it's so pretty
there's a photo of the star ingredient
on top for both I really like that it's
got the instructions on the back which i
think is really important because if you
check out the paper packaging you'll
just left with this so tells you how to
use it how often to use it really nice
coating as well so it shows you morning
and night so it's got like a little Sun
and a moon every single day applying to
wet skin unfortunately Craig beauty only
ships to the u.s. and South Korea for
now but they do have worldwide shipping
in the works
[Music]
callaloo you callaloo you is the first
of the supplement series
it's got 5.25% glycolic acid at a pH of
3.5 to 4 so it's weaker than most
exfoliant you'll find but it's not so
low that the glycolic acid is like a
vanity ingredient that does nothing the
glycolic acid is in a base of soothing
and hydrating aloe water and butylene
glycol it's also got lots of
antioxidants in it which are great for
potentially reducing free radical damage
so it's got kale spinach and parsley
extracts it's also got lots of hydrating
and soothing ingredients which i think
is really really good so it's got
hyaluronic acid panthenol which is also
called vitamin b5 allantoin allantoin is
particularly good for calming down
irritation so if this very gentle
exfoliator does actually cause any
irritation it won't be as much of an
issue because you've got these anti
irritants in there this product is
really gentle and I think callaloo you
is really really good for beginners who
are just starting to use an alpha
hydroxy acid it's really good for
flattening out texture dealing with
congestion clogged pores and give you
that glowy look it's recommended that
you use this two to three times a week
but in reality if your skin is quite
used to alpha hydroxy exfoliants you can
probably just use it every night I've
been using it every night the most
similar product that I have in my stash
to kala lujah is pixie glow tonic pixie
glow tonic has 5% glycolic acid at pH 4
to 5 and the lower the pH the more
active the acid is so callaloo Yu is a
little bit stronger than glow tonic
white honey also has aloe vera as the
base as well just like hallelujah it's
also got a few different extracts like
witch hazel and horse chestnut and
they're both above 5% and it's also got
a tiny bit of ginseng extract the big
difference between the true in my
opinion is probably the fact that pixie
glow tonic is fragranced and it's no
a particularly weak fragrance that sort
of moderate but it can bother some
people Kahlua is actually cheaper than
glow tonic it's $25 for 200 mils versus
$15 for 100 mils and this is in US
dollars so this is how much it would be
if you bought it in America in Australia
glow tonic is actually a bit more
expensive so Cala lujah is an even
better bargain I personally find that
glow tonic is nice but my skin loves
exfoliation so I prefer a stronger
product callaloo has also got more
humectants and it's a bit more hydrating
on my dehydration prone skin and it's
light and gentle enough that I can use
it daily I've been using color lujah on
my face right after cleansing it's
recommended that you use it on a cotton
pad so you pour a little bit out and
then swipe it over your face but wasting
product hurts my soul a little bit so I
use it without the cotton pad and I just
pour it on my face part on my face I
pour it on my hand and then I Pat it on
so I guess the part of my hands are
probably going to be really nice and
glowing soon I find it really nice to
have colu you as an option in my stash
there's not that many products like this
on the market it's perfect for hydrating
skin and giving you gentle low-key
exfoliation without worrying about
stressing out your skin too much
especially if it's already irritated
from other ingredients like retinol
make sure when you're using any alpha
hydroxy acid product you use sunscreen
as well alpha hydroxy acids can cause
photosensitivity for a week after you
use it it doesn't really matter whether
you use alpha hydroxy acids in the
morning or night since the
photosensitivity
increases for so long afterwards anyway
but I personally prefer using it at
night if you haven't used an alpha
hydroxy acid product before you might
get a bit of purging but the soothing
ingredients should reduce the chances of
that and if you want to find out more
about purging I've got a whole video
about it and how to tell if your skin is
purging or just breaking out
so overall callaloo you love it the
Marsha hemp hydrating cleanser this is
the first of the core series and it's a
very gentle cleanser it's $16 for 120
mils it contains a whopping 40% marcha
now if you look up studies on putting
march on your skin you won't actually
find any studies because March is not
really the word they use in the
literature you can find green tea
studies though so March is actually a
form of green tea which has even more
antioxidants than normal green tea
contains chemicals called polyphenols
that can act as antioxidants
antioxidants are substances that can
soak up damage from free radicals free
radicals are really reactive species
that have an unpaired electron free
radicals formed from all sorts of things
so environmental stressors like UV light
and pollution and smoking if you're a
smoker they can also form from just
normal biological processes so free
radicals are important chemical
messengers in your body but if they're
in the wrong place because they're so
reactive they can attack other things
inside your body so things like cell
membranes lipids DNA so this free
radical damage which is also sometimes
called oxidative stress can build up and
then it leads to things like skin aging
the key antioxidant polyphenol in green
tea is called epic Gallic catechin 3
galley or EGCG
it has 25 to 100 times as much
antioxidant ability as things like
vitamin C and E green tea also has a
bunch of other polyphenols which are
really antioxidant as well and these are
going to be really difficult for me to
say epicatechin epicatechin 3 gal 8 and
epic gallo catechin the way crave beauty
describes why they put marker in this
product is that they thought it it'd be
awesome to splash much on your face
every day and I totally agree this
cleanser has a pH of 5 to 6 which is
really good for skin so cleansers
contain ingredients called surfactants
which is what does the cleansing the
problem with surfactants is that they
can disturb your skin so as well as
removing the lipids from your skin which
your skin needs it can also bind to
proteins in your skin and change their
structure which makes your skin barrier
more leaky and this also makes them more
vulnerable to pH changes so high ph
cleansers are really bad for your skin
because they can change your skin pH for
extended amounts of time the reason this
is bad for skin is that it tends to
interfere with the normal biological
processes in your skin that help it grow
and repair and exfoliate itself all of
these biological processes tend to be pH
dependent it's also got other nice
ingredients in it like hemp seed oil
sweet almond oil and oat extract which
is really soothing for your skin another
ingredient in this cleanser which I
think deserves a bit of cred is methyl
glue c10 it's not a really well known
ingredient probably because its name is
so uncapped
but it's ingredient number 5 and it's
been in a few products that I've been
really liking lately
matcha hemp cleanser uses gentle
surfactants CellScope cocoa bean which
is a sweeter ionic surfactant and non
ionic surfactants like cocoa glucoside
and deckle glucoside it's also got surf
bark extract which contains more non
ionic surfactants I'm obsessed with
gentle surfactants and my cleanses
because of my dehydration prone skin my
skin gets really sensitive when I use
too many harsh surfactants they make my
skin really tight and itchy and
uncomfortable and it makes it a little
bit bumpy and it makes my pores look
even
so gentle cleansing is probably my
number one skincare need another thing I
really like about this cleanser is that
it has a metric buttload of glycerine in
it it's the third ingredient listen is
probably my favorite boring skincare
ingredient it's a cheap humectant which
is really good at attracting and holding
onto water and it's naturally already in
your skin glycerin seems to have more
special properties than fancy humectants
like hyaluronic acid it can actually get
into the stratum corneum and stay there
for ages so it's really really good for
dehydrated skin the cleanser itself is a
clear slightly greenish brown gel and it
lathers up a little bit it spreads
really really well on your skin so you
actually don't need very much I keep
squeezing a little bit too much and then
I end up washing my face and my neck is
on my chest as well it smells a little
bit chemically probably because it's
fragrance free I really like that this
cleanser gets rid of extra oil on my
skin without stripping it afterwards my
skin still feels really plump and soft
and not tight or squeaky which usually
means that my skin is drying out it's
not amazing at makeup removal but it's
OK at removing light makeup I think
using it by itself on days when I stay
at home and don't actually wear much on
my face and I've been using it after
cleansing oil on days when I do wear
lots of makeup I've been using this
daily in the shower and I even tried it
in the morning over the sink once which
is a pretty big deal for me I hate
washing my face over the sink my
bathroom set up really badly so every
time I try to wash my face over the sink
I end up bumping my head into the vanity
I used tons of water to try to get the
cleanser off it splashes everywhere it
goes all the way all over the mirror and
there's little water drops on it
afterwards and then it dries something
you have those little water marks and it
really really annoys me and then when I
try to wipe off the water marks I leave
lint all over the mirror and it's just
impossible to get clean so I hate hate
hate sink washing but I tried it over
the sink it doesn't work well it works
but nothing works for me over the sink
sir unfortunately I wish I could
this cleanser convinced me to stop
washing my face over the sink but no it
seems like nothing is going to ever do
that
[Music]
overall I'm really really impressed with
these products they're really gentle and
soothing and they slosh in so easily
into my routine I'm not really surprised
by how good they are because Leah's got
similar skin Jermaine
she's got oily dehydrated and slightly
sensitive skin as well plus she has been
reviewing beauty products for ages and
she worked out one of the biggest
manufacturers of beauty products in
Korea so she's had tons of experience
with products and she knows what works
well for her and what works well for me
apparently these are fantastic for
dehydrated skin I'm really looking
forward to seeing what crave beauty
comes out with next I've seen that
Leah's been talking about sunscreen on
her Instagram and I know she's a big fan
of my favorite filters the tennis orbs
S&M so I can't wait to see those
products thanks so much for watching my
review if you like my videos you can
subscribe to my channel if you have any
requests for videos please let me know
you can also follow me on Instagram and
Facebook and of course I also have tons
of beauty science on my blog see you
next time for more beauty science talk
[Music]
[Music]